Lannister Baratheon stark Tyrell they're
all just spokes on a wheel
this one's on top then that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground
I'm not going to stop the wheel
[Music]
I'm going to break the wheel
Stannis Baratheon has an army at Castle
black he means to take the north this is
the time and I will risk everything
winter is coming
we know what's coming with it we can
learn to live with the wildlings
we can add them to the army of the Dead
you have a few we are the many
we serve the gods and the gods demand
justice
this city up to the rats to Noah left to
hide
I am a queen not a butcher
all rulers are either butchers don't
meet
hey youtubers is Charlie so this gonna
be my breakdown of the new Game of
Thrones footage they premiered it to
announce their new HBO now service so
I'll explain what's going on with that
after I get through the breakdown and
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a copy of the season 4
DVD so here we go so we open up on
King's Landing there's actually a good
shot of bear Lowe except right there in
the middle rising above everything else
it's nice for shadowing for the
powershift in King's Landing with the
coming of the high Sparrow
so she on her way to see the high
Sparrow probably for the first time most
most of this footage is from the first
couple of episodes but with a few
exceptions he lives in and around Baylor
cept if you remember a day-in-the-life
special that they aired they talked
about filming in his special sets the
high Sparrow doesn't live in luxury like
a lot of the previous high septons so
the area around Baylor Sept is pretty
humble and he uses those resources in
and around there to feed the poor as you
can tell he's not going to be a big fan
of Lannister gold
Daenerys narration goes across a lot of
these opening scenes when she's talking
about breaking the wheel she's talking
about breaking the game of Thrones which
is like start Baratheon
it's a cycle that goes on and on
crushing those on the ground she's
talking about the peasantry it crushes
the peasantry she's gonna spend a lot of
time in Mereen trying to help the slaves
but it draws a nice link between her and
what the high Sparrow is trying to do
they have very different methods but
they're both trying to help the least
fortunate which i think is kind of
interesting whenever I was reading the
books I never really thought of Daenerys
as being like the high Sparrow
but I like the trailer points us in that
direction here we have Stannis Baratheon
up at the wall it looks like they're
getting ready to sacrifice someone it
looks like Melisandre is getting ready
to burn someone at the stake there's a
later shot of solis Baratheon like like
almost crying on the snowy ground so it
might have something to do with her
maybe not because it doesn't look those
scenes happen sequentially remember they
have Shireen Baratheon at the wall so
they might be substituting her for one
of the other characters in the books but
she also went to the wall in the books
too so they could just be adapting her
part straight off the page
but typically typically what Dan and
Dave do is they'll give certain
characters storylines that they're not
doing that they don't include to other
characters that they've already cast
from previous seasons here Sansa up
towards the north of the area it looks
like you can see a banner from house
Arryn in the background isn't it awesome
how she starting to look more and more
like Catelyn here's Arya with her coin
since she's in a stone
room lying down it looks like she might
be inside the house of black and white
at this point this is an old shot of
Marjorie from the previous trailer with
the Queen of thorns it looks like this
might be connected with the Loras clip
that's later in the trailer we see
Laura's getting dragged away from a
trial with the high Sparrow he being a
very religious man probably doesn't look
very kindly on some of the rumors about
Sir Loras as the audience and it
especially in the books we have a lot
more information about what all the
characters are doing so it's always
funny DC characters speculate about each
other
like when people talk about Sir Loras
being gay like they think he is but
they're not quite sure like they never
caught him in the act
but obviously is the audience we know
exactly what's going on same goes for
Cersei with the twincest and sleeping
around just in general despite the
rumors she has not slept with the entire
population of King's Landing and no not
all of them are related to her maybe a
little bit though maybe a little bit
this is Daenerys meeting with his DAR
interesting that right after that we get
a shot of these masked people fighting
with the unsullied I think this kind of
answers the question as to who they are
so I think these are the sons of the
harpy a lot of people thought they might
be the brazen beasts the brazen beasts
are actually a group that Daenerys forms
the sons of the harpy are her enemies
since we see them rushing daznak spit
later in the trailer I think that
anything there's also confirmation so
people in the masks equal not good since
this is followed directly by a Tyrion
Varys scene it's possible that they
could go straight to marine but I think
they go to Pentos first based on the
scene where beerus is explaining the
Tyrian the plan that he has like what he
wants him to do so this could be either
of those places here's Tom and
Marjorie's wedding looks like Cersei is
super happy to see Margery join the
family she's really clinging to Tommen
this season the funny thing is as
Margaery doesn't seem super sinister
like she just wants the iron throw it's
not like she wants to hurt Tommen she
doesn't want to kill him Cersei starts
to flip a little so as bad as she is
she just wants she wants to hold on to
her family and marcela is still in Dorne
so Tommen is like the last thing that
she has I'll be really interested to see
if Jaime behaves the same way he does
during book 4 if you have read the books
just use spoiler tags you want to
comment on his and searched these
relationship and the way it changes it
reminds me of this really awesome
Princess Leia quote when she's talking
to Grand Moff Tarkin the more you
tighten your grasp the more star systems
will slip through your fingers
the
people in black robes of the faith
militant in King's Landing they're
getting rid of all the debaters stuff
like I said high Sparrow not a huge fan
of the trappings of wealth here's a shot
of Daenerys and des nag spit more
fighting between the unsullied and the
sons of the harpy here's Jon Snow
leading a force up to hardhome his
narration kind of explains what he's
trying to do when he's talking about the
army that dead I know it sounds like
he's talking about the Brotherhood and
Stannis's army but I think he's also
trying to prevent them from joining the
literal army of the Dead as in the army
the White Walkers so technically he's
trying to help them but it doesn't look
like they want to be helped here's
Tyrion who looks like he sees drogon
flying over his ship there was the
poster that they released with with
drogon hanging over him but it's hard to
tell if you know that was actually going
to happen or if that was just something
that they mashed together like the lion
meets the dragon tyrion spends a lot of
time reading about dragons all across
the book so I'll be interested to see
how they explore that on the TV show a
lot of the time that we see him doing
that is part of the young grift story
and that looks like it's pretty much
been cut out I know a lot of your
commenting that drogon doesn't look like
he got a lot bigger but I think the time
jump is just much shorter usually like
that first episode of each new season
picks up in the moments after the finale
from the previous season so like when we
see Arya for instance she was like the
last moment in season 4 that first
episode will probably feature her on the
ship like we won't just see her in
Braavos already this is newly up jumped
Ramsay Bolton with Miranda if you don't
remember Miranda she was the one with
ramsay chasing the other girl in season
four like that they when they were
hunting humans for sport she seems like
she's kind of an evil girl but I don't
know if she's enjoying this or not it's
hard to tell Ramsay's all over the place
it seems like she's gonna have a bigger
part this season they might give her the
fake Arya plot from the books this blew
my mind the first time I saw it because
it looks like Sansa is in the stark
family crypts underneath Winterfell and
remember the Bolton's were heading to
Winterfell
so if Sansa is also in Winterfell that's
like a big WTF later in the trailer it
even seems like there are house
Aaron guards like the ones that are
riding around with her and Littlefinger
entering Winterfell so Littlefinger
might have some sort of plot to ally
himself with the Bolton's as part as
part of some grand scheme that he's
concocting but if you read the books you
know what he's planning to do with Sansa
here's some early shots of the fighting
pits because we stay
on this character right here with the
helmet on this might be Serge aura like
this might be his start in the fighting
pits he just he appears throughout the
trailer the shadow Melisandre is really
awesome too it looks like she is taken
aback so this might be some sort of
Associated white Walker scene they
haven't appeared in the trailers yet
hoping to see them in the third trailer
there's usually like three trailers
before the season starts anything that
makes Melisandre make that face makes me
really excited this is Stannis mapping
flayed men troop locations of the Bolton
troop locations the awesome thing is is
that we get narration from Roose Bolton
in the background it's not Stannis
talking I'll be interested to see if
they take this to its logical conclusion
and we see a Bolton versus Stannis fight
that would definitely be winds of winter
territory here's more shots from the
wildlings up at hardhome fighting jon
and his forces this is really fun in the
indus in OPS's for the first episode it
says Brienne and pod run into some
trouble but this actually looks like it
happens later like they're caught in the
snowstorm so it looks like they're
travelling slowly further north they
might be heading for Winterfell it's
hard to tell we see pot here caught
between Brienne who's getting ready to
take someone down it's hard to tell who
it is exactly they run into that gives
them trouble it could be the Brotherhood
without banners
it could be House Arryn men here's a
really awesome line the high Sparrow
says the gods demand justice it's
basically him saying that he's getting
ready to start a holy war not
necessarily against Daenerys or any
anybody outside Westeros but against
corruption as he sees it inside King's
Landing inside the realm which is bad
news for anyone who does anything that
the church does not approve of here's
the sand snakes in Dorne just doing some
training I'd say of all the places in
season five all of the new locations
Braavos and door are the two that I'm
looking forward to the most here's a
better shot at Jaime and Bronn fighting
the Dornish soldiers these are scenes
from the previous trailer just from
different angles Daenerys in bed with
Daario and then here's just a really
awesome self-explanatory shot of
Daenerys watching Drogo and fly off the
top of the pyramid he's the only one
that isn't caged up if he'd have been
around at the end of season 4 Daenerys
would have had to chain him up
underneath the pyramid - but because he
was off flying around like he was too
big to contain he remained free so he's
continued to grow where the other
dragons are still a little bit smaller
but if you're wondering I definitely
think he's strong enough to carry her I
mean it Daenerys is a pretty small
person to begin with so HBO now stuff it
looks like it's going to be available at
the beginning of April it's going to be
on Apple platforms in the App Store
you probably be able to watch it on that
website to HBO now calm but you guys
would really love this so here's the
subscription details it's $15 a month
the first month like whenever you sign
up for the service the first month is
free so that $15 that you pay is for the
second month because it's so cheap but
I'm probably going to do is whenever I
start giving away subscriptions I'll
give away like two per give away don't
forget to I also have the signed copies
of a feast for crows and dance with
dragons that'll be part of my episode
one giveaway so that would be like April
12th whenever I post my episode 1 video
really I'm just happy about this HBO now
service just because it means everybody
can watch it at the same time I'm
assuming what they're going to do is
they'll make episodes available when
they first air on television like across
all platforms simultaneously so my next
bonus video is going to be a character
video I'll post that next Sunday be sure
to subscribe to get it if you have on
already feel free to leave requests I
have settled on a couple characters I
want to do videos for but I'm always
open to suggestion if you haven't seen
it already you can click here for my
breakdown of the first three episodes
and you can click here for my Sansa
video thank you so much watching I'll
see you guys tonight
now let's all do the thing
you